hello there now you may be wondering
what is so fast about a camera well I'll
show you when you take a picture with a
regular viewfinder camera you're not
actually looking down the same lens
that's taking the picture you're looking
down a separate viewfinder lens and in
some situations that gives you a slight
difference in perspective because it's
only an approximation of what your
picture is going to be now a way around
that is by using an SLR camera which
stands for single lens reflex that's
pretty much exactly what it is there's
only one lens there's no separate
viewfinder lens now that requires a
little bit of cleverness behind the lens
there's actually a mirror placed at 45
degrees that blocks the sensor which
means you can look through the
viewfinder down and through the exact
lens it's going to take a picture so
that leads us on to the very fast part
when you take a picture you'll hear this
sound didn't sound like much but
actually quite a lot just happen there
and you'll notice that in the viewfinder
your vision was blocked
we're very split-second so the only way
we're going to see what actually happens
is by taking off the lens zooming the
phantom in and filming this a
ridiculously high frame rate we'll start
with a thirtieth of a second now you're
looking at the mirror which is in front
of the shutter when I press down the
button the mirror flips up out of the
way and temporarily blocks the
viewfinder then the shutter comes down
whoosh now light is exposing on the
sensor and then the shutter closes again
followed by the mirror coming back down
so you can see through the viewfinder
again as you can see from that clip this
camera has a mechanical shutter that
moves out of the way and allows light to
hit the sensor a very fundamental part
photography is the duration of your
exposure has very different effects on
the image and you can control that with
a shutter speed for example a relatively
long exposure of say 2 seconds will give
you a bright image but anything that
moved within those 2 seconds would have
a trail of motion blur behind it so not
ideal for filming a fast-moving subject
for a very fast-moving subject you would
want a much shorter shutter duration the
fastest this camera will do it is an
eight thousandth of a second which looks
like this so now what we'll do is we'll
use the Phantom to film different
shutter speeds of the camera and see how
they all compare to each other in slow
motion honestly these are probably going
to look
identical in real-time but we'll
definitely able to see the difference in
slow-mo so we'll start with five
hundredths of a second
one thousandth of a second
eh mm of a second
for thousands of a second
and eight thousandth of a second
let's have a look at the four fastest
one side by side just to see the
comparison
this kind of stuff is fascinating to me
it makes me wonder how many people take
for granted what's happening inside that
camera when they take a picture the fact
that the shutter is made of two clusters
of metal blades but at their shortest
duration I'm moving right next to each
other allowing just the smallest slit of
light to hit the sensor this is also a
great visual representation of why you
need so much light for a high shutter
speed shot because the amount of time
the light is hitting the sensor is so
short you end up with a much darker
image there are many types of shutter
that a camera can have this is a
mechanical shutter but there's also an
electronic shutter which doesn't have
any moving parts in video mode this will
actually use an electronic shutter it
basically takes an image 30 times every
second without covering the sensor this
camera shutter is also a rolling shutter
which is the opposite of a global
shutter and what that means is is that
it doesn't actually take the whole image
at the same time you may have noticed
from the slo-mo that the image is taken
from the top to the bottom of the sensor
that basically means that whenever you
take a picture the top of the picture is
actually older than the bottom by a
fraction of a second and technically
that statement should be flipped as
everything traveled through a lens is
actually upside down by the time it gets
to the sensor the electronic shutter on
this camera when it's in video mode
works in the exact same way it takes
each line of pixels from top to bottom
because it doesn't have the power to
take the whole image at once and this
can lead to some interesting artifacts
when filming certain subjects you may
remember this video from a few years ago
I was blasting down in the face with a
core I don't know it's editing with
video I noticed something really weird
in the Canon footage on this one frame
of video the cork is suspended in the
air but the shadow of the court has
already hit him in the face luckily we
had the Phantom right by its side so we
can analyze exactly what happened with
the Canon there so imagine the color
going down the screen as the Canon
acquiring each frame of its video
nothing happening in this frame watch
this one as it gets down to the cork
firing it then hits the shadow and that
explains why there are two different
moments in time at different heights in
the same frame almost any camera you use
these days to shoot video will have a
rolling shutter and that's due to the
frequency of CMOS sensors being used in
DSLRs and pretty much every smartphone
and you can test this out by pointing
your
outside the window of a moving car and
just filming trees and poles that go by
you'll notice that everything that's
vertical will be slightly skewed
diagonally because the object is moving
as it's being scanned from top to bottom
or bottom to top
there's definitely pros and cons to both
the global and the rolling shutter
for example the Phantom flex as a global
shutter which makes it much better for
the scientific analysis of shots as
every moment in the frame was taken at
the exact same time a phantom flex 4k
has a rolling shutter but is typically
used on movies and TV where it seems to
be quite natural for the human eye to
look at before in this video I feel like
I should say a few words about the state
of this camera it's a Canon 7d I bought
it right before I started this lemon
guys and I've used it in every single
episode to film the real time segments
and has taken an absolute pounding it's
been in the splash zone a few times it's
right on the lens splodge it's fallen
over the screwloose I've just noticed
but I refuse to replace it because it
still works so I hope you enjoyed that
video maybe you learned something be
sure to follow me on Twitter I tweet
stuff you can buy a shirt you can
subscribe thanks for watching
you